un análisis de la revista estadounidense
the atlantic sugiere que se está
gestando un golpe a la democracia
estadounidense por parte de tron y sus
seguidores y en el cita ejemplos como
teorías conspirativas y artimañas para
desacreditar el sistema electoral que
tan seria es hoy la amenaza para la
democracia estadounidense
primero que todo muchas gracias a andrés
por invitarme a tu espacio la realidad
es que el líder acaba de sacar un
informe donde estamos hablando de que
estas teorías conspirativas de que las
elecciones del 2020 fueron
robadas siguen vivas estamos en un
circuito muy peligroso de
retroalimentación de falsedades
amplificado casi a diario por el ex
presidente de sus aliados y por personas
dedicadas a la desinformación de la
derecha que está creando este ambiente
altamente combustible para crear lo que
estamos llamando ss sis
es clima perfecto para la violencia
política señora gestión en que van las
investigaciones el departamento de
justicia anunció recientemente que
castigará a los responsables en todos
los niveles
llevan a nada
identifica 2 727 personas que fueron
partes de esta insurrección en enero del
año pasado
aproximadamente es 20% de las personas
que participaron tienen aficiones
directas con grupos extremistas con
grupos antigubernamentales
pero el problema más específico es que
el 80% de los individuos que
participaron en esta insurrección son
personas como tú y yo personas que no
tenían ninguna afiliación extremista
ideológica y que sin embargo decidieron
participar en esta tu multa que d se
desencadenó en la violencia que vimos en
el capitolio y en que están hoy por hoy
los grupos de extrema derecha y de
supremacistas blancos que participaron
de manera violenta en la toma al
capitolio son más fuertes son más
débiles que hace un año
siguen con el mismo mensaje siguen
participando en estas teorías
conspiratorias siguen promoviendo
falsedades en los medios de redes
sociales y siguen con seguidores sino
buscamos maneras de aliviar estas
falsedades de traer a la población en un
solo mensaje de que estamos en una
democracia y respetar el proceso
democrático hay realidades que pueden
sugerir de que estos grupos tengan más
alimentos para crear otro
evento de este tipo